as a result of the global coronavirus
pandemic 30 million small businesses
around the country were suddenly faced
with closures and needed help
immediately as a result of the 2
trillion dollar care stimulus package
350 billion dollars of that was
earmarked for the payment protection
program which was primarily instituted
to help small businesses keep their
employees on staff many of the small
mom-and-pop businesses that needed the
cash the most were left out my
colleagues and I spent the weekend
speaking to about two dozen bankers and
businesses and come through SBA data and
hundreds of securities filings to get to
the bottom of the story what surprised
us most was just discovering that in the
rush to dole out the funds the bank's
prioritize existing customers with
high-level relationships within the top
ranks their rationale even if the loans
were a hundred percent guaranteed it was
better to deal with the businesses they
knew best as a result their own banks
couldn't fund their loans even if they
wanted to which forced businesses to all
rush to apply with a different lender
they had no prior relationship with
unfortunately all of those Small
Business Administration lenders were so
overwhelmed they chose to prioritize
their own customers first and most
didn't even get through those the point
of the Paycheck protection program was
to help many of these smaller businesses
that don't have the liquidity that these
public companies do and/or the backing
of millionaire or billionaire investors
all of these people are suffering at a
much greater level than than the public
companies I spoke to one of these small
business owners that applied and didn't
get any money the owner of a pediatric
clinic in Salt Lake City
a little empty this morning I applied
for the PPP long the very morning it
opened up it was a Friday I believe two
weeks ago I knew that it was a capped
process I knew going into it that it
would be a first-come first-serve basis
so there was some mild anxiety
associated with making sure I got the
application in in a timely manner my
banker reached out to me and said
unfortunately the money ran out
I was told that I was in line to be
funded but the the money ran out before
my loan was approved we will have a
shortfall this month without the PPP
money we are actively working on ways to
make up those funds and as the owners of
the business we've committed to keep our
employees employed and we're just not
going to get paid until we get these
funds in place not every business was
denied though there were some businesses
that did receive the money we specialize
in helping people book hotel rooms for
groups amends conferences and for
individual travel our business went down
90% overnight we're an independent
company so we actually have no outside
capital all the capital is from profits
and what our turnover so it's really
where we're very self-reliant as a firm
but we said in this case you know we
needed to get some assistance so we were
following the government loan process
that's very very very closely that isn't
going to happen is not going to happen
one of the terms and conditions so
there's a lot of questions up until the
last minute and we decided that those
are district cash flow purposes we
really need to get to the next couple of
months because people aren't traveling
we've submitted it on Friday got
reviewed Saturday we had our funding on
Tuesday we applied for a 1.4 million and
we received 1.4 million
flowing primarily towards payroll so
it's a it's really making sure that like
we reduce a lot of people's hours so we
said okay listen now you can work you
can work full hours now and when you do
salaries you know by 50% our CEO took no
salary you get a service customer so
imagine if I had to cut my staff 50%
and then people calling up they want
refunds and they want to make bookings
we want to make cancels they want to
make changes and very very hard to do
that I think what we're all for company
like ours is going to make a huge
difference on April 21st the Senate
passed an additional 320 billion in
funding to replenish the paycheck
protection program with 60 billion of
that money earmarked for small and
mid-sized banks community based lenders
and credit unions another 60 billion has
been set aside for the economic injury
disaster loan assistance program a
separate lending program directly
administered by the SBA hopefully the
money will actually be administered in a
more equitable way but I'm not sure that
it's still enough I think that
longer-term getting these small
businesses back to work and back into a
position where they are above water and
can pay back these loans which are in
some cases forgivable and in other cases
not is going to be a long road ahead